près de la vérité en ayant bien insisté
sur le fait qu on a aimé pendant dix ans
que c'était notre fils fait tout ce
qu'il fallait pour eux il a toujours
aimé et qu'il fallait priver de ce
carcan de vigny dans lequel et des
accusations contre stéphanie grégory
c'est tellement odieuse
vitaly faction folie cette utilisation
parce que l'on connaît aujourd'hui où le
pour ma collection à vocal parties
civiles le bateau au port de joie mais
la famille nous la connaissions la
vérité et la vérité elle est reconnue
par l'auteur du meurtre
et c'est ça qui est important c'est que
maintenant il n'y a plus je voudrais
disgression d'élucubrations et c'est
très bien comme ça
monsieur laval a reconnu être le
meurtrier le seul meurtrier à son
domicile de son épouse et avoir
transporté le comble c'est sale je
dirais la nouvelle importante de la
journée ultime au bout du spanc mais qui
cette fois ci certainement le dernier
naturellement qu'ils lavent les parties
civiles de tout soupçon mais ça personne
ne croyait aux élucubrations de laval
mais le bâtonnier partage ou à moi même
sommes naturellement soulagé et
satisfait que j'atteins de laval se soit
conduit de manière responsable et
aujourd'hui pour une femme en homme est
reconnu ça reste un sacré sens et place
avec la matinée on appris hier on a
cherché et il se dérober
il a fallu l'intervention de votre
intervention madame pour que dire
l'émotion l'on porte mieux si on donnait
ce qu'ils reconnaissent ses
responsabilités pour pleine et entière
et unique